Our administration has had some political setbacks this year....
...and some of them were deserved.
But I wake up every day...
...knowing that they are nothing...
...compared to the setbacks that families all across this country have faced this year.
And what keeps me going,...
...what keeps me fighting...
...is that despite all these setbacks,...
...that spirit of determination and optimism,...
...that fundamental decency that has always been at the core of the American people,...
...that lives on.
It lives on in the struggling small business owner who wrote to me of his company.
None of us, he said,...
...are willing to consider, even slightly, that we might fail.
It lives on in the woman who said, that...
...even though she and her neighbors have felt the pain of recession,...
..."We are strong."
"We are resilient."
"We are American."
It lives on in the 8-year-old boy in Louisiana...
...who just sent me his allowance and asked if I would give it to the people of Haiti.
And it lives on in all the Americans...
...who've dropped everything to go someplace they've never been...
...and pull people they've never known from the rubble,...
...prompting chants of "U.S.A. U.S.A. U.S.A." when another life was saved.
The spirit that has sustained this nation for more than two centuries lives on in you,...
...its people.
We have finished a difficult year.
We have come through a difficult decade.
But a new year has come.
A new decade stretches before us.
We don't quit.
I don't quit.
Let's seize this moment...
...to start anew,...
...to carry the dream forward...
...and to strengthen our union once more.
Thank you! God bless you!
And God bless the United States of America.